hi i'm patrick redding creative director
on gotham knights
on behalf of the whole team at wb games
montreal
i'm really honored to give you a quick
look at our gameplay
elliott center is covered in ice
whatever's causing this
is localized at the top
we're going to look at a short clip from
one of gotham knight's villain crimes
in a pre-alpha build
this mission is halfway through the mr
freeze storyline
and we're playing batgirl a dozen or so
hours into her character progression
[Music]
all units at elliott center air support
inbound
hostiles opening fire on upper floors
air support can you do a fly around
freeze has recently returned to gotham
with a mysterious agenda that involves
manipulating the weather to flash freeze
the city
an important goal for gotham knights is
that players can play all of the game
either solo or in two-player co-op
robin's learned how to access the
justice league satellite for short-range
teleportation
and while that girl has mastered some
more familiar techniques
and developed a few new ones of our own
montoya here heard you're down there
having some fun finds one word for it
just a heads up that chopper's under
orders to fire on anything that moves
inside
your weapons
the storm is getting worse you need to
hurry and find a way
inside alien center the gcpd chopper
made that part easy
this doesn't look up to code
if anyone asks i meant to do that
i won't say a word
tours were still going on when freeze
came through
those poor people they didn't stand a
chance
gotham knights is built to let players
approach each challenge with their
preferred style and their preferred
build
this will only take a second
keep them occupied
[Music]
no precision
[Music]
dad you're it
[Music]
uh not the safest time to take the
elevator
you'd rather take the stairs
these cables on the floor guaranteed
they lead the freeze
now
almost there
i see the weather machine ready with the
disrupter that thing's drawing so much
power
feel this rusher's in place
it's charging
get away from my storm engine is that
what you're calling it
you don't want to be on the roof when
this disruptor goes off trust me
irrelevant
i already have what i need
the storm has risen over copper
nothing can stop it
[Music]
an important element of gotham knights
is that as the player increases in power
and ability
their foes keep pace so confronting a
villain like mr freeze can be a very
different proposition at level five
or at level 15 and not just in terms of
stats but in
the kinds of attacks and defenses they
bring to bear
and that was just a short peek at gotham
knights we're going to have more to show
you in the future
you